what's up guys I'm going to be showing
you how you can out for profit with a
bunch of different methods so let's go
ahead and let's get started so for the
first method I'm going to be doing items
that are normally profitable when aling
so for example I'm doing dehy bodies so
I went ahead and checked the prices on
nature runes and they're 243 right now
and I bought and sold all the um dehy
bodies for Max minimum price and right
now the only ones that are for profit
are the green dragonhide bodies and the
black dragon High bodies so the the
black dragon hiide bodies for 80 I mean
the ALK for
8088 so minus the
784 248 so that's profit right
there and then the um the green blue
hide bodies 46
80 minus the
4425 and that's profit so I'm going to
go ahead and buy these and I'll be back
when I have them bought so the Black
dead bodies are taking too long so I'm
going to go ahead and just collect all
these um the buy limit's 125 for each of
them so if you buy them overnight you'll
make a lot more money um so I'm going to
go ahead and Al these and I'll tell you
guys what the profits are so quick note
sadly I forgot that I wasn't recording
the calculator so you guys aren't going
to be able to see the math but I'll
leave something down in the description
that tells the math of how I outed them
what the prices were and how much profit
I made from them so you guys can
actually see the numb so sorry about
that thanks all right I'm done so let's
go ahead and see how much profit we
made so okay I forgot to check this so I
got to check this real quick okay
so let's write this down okay a mill
138 392 okay um so we'll check the
good okay we'll check this so we got to
add all the prices together so first
let's do
1, minus 807 to get the nature
runes so 193
time
243 so need
rooms 46 899
so we'll do the
029 plus the
so
um 997 9977 I
mean okay so we got to do the
the price the total amount that we have
minus that number so
32 minus
899 minus
977 okay see the profits minimal but the
idea is this way you're not spending any
money when you're doing nature runes
when you're uh doing
highi so let's go to the next method so
now the next method we're going to be
Telly grabbing zammy wines while we're
alking so teleport to fador bring what
you want to ALK bring your nature runes
bring your law runes bring in battle an
air staff I mean a fire staff and while
you're running directly north from fador
just go ahead and start alking your your
alks and then once you get there start T
grabing wines and switching back and
forth between alking and T grabing all
right I'm done um I'm not sure how long
it took but um the hardest part is
because there's Bots here but I found
this guy shout out to RH games he's just
a cool dude he's kind of near to the
game he said um we just talked for a
little bit he seems like a cool dude but
anyway um so I'll go back to the GE and
then I'll tell you what the profits were
and yeah all right now I'm at the GE I'm
going to go ahead and um do the math of
how much money I made so it cost
133,50 for the
logs I
used 200 law
runes time 243
48,000
48,600 and then the profit that I made
is let's
see let's instance sell these also use
28 lawn
runs so
4,760 okay so now let's do the profit I
made minus all those numbers
so
488 minus 1 33
450 minus
0 minus
4760 okay so I made about 46 cave from
alkine and um Telly grabbing wines so
46k profit that's about 50K so it's a
good method let's go to the next one so
the next method is we're going to be
tanning blue dragon HIDs into Dragon
Leathers at the Alid tanning guy and
we're going to be running back and forth
between the bank and the tanning guy but
um so what you need for this you need
something you're going to Al I went
ahead and brought got out a Mill and I
bought some alks I don't know how many
I'm going to use but I'm going to the
margins right now are about over 200 GP
but I'm just going to instant buy them
right now um I'll do a 100 of them for
this
video and
so you're going to want to do this but
um additionally you're going to want to
have stamina pot
probably so you need your
glory um weight reducing armor would
help but I'm too lazy right now so once
you get to alth Creator you're going to
want to take a drink of your stamina
potion potion put it back in take out
your dragon hides you're going run over
here to this tan guy you're going to
need
I'm not sure what he charges but I
started with a mill so that'll tell us
how much we made and then click all so
20 coins each and then just run back and
while you're while you're running back
you're going to want to do alks I forgot
my fire staff but you're going to want
to do alks in between so this is what it
would look like you're going to run back
and forth you're going to Al while
you're running
there and then you're going to go ahead
and tan you're going to go ahead and
find the guy trade
him select all and then run
back and it's that simple I'll show you
guys when I'm done so I way
underestimated that I'm going to go
ahead and go buy more um blue dragon
hides and then when I'm done alking I'll
show you guys how much you make all
right I'm done so I'm going to teleport
to the Grand exchange and I'm going to
go ahead and sell these
so let's see um I didn't finish my Al
when I did 350 of them um I'll just go
ahead and inst s
these so I'm just going to sell the rest
of
these um if you don't sell them all in
the alal you'll make a lot more so
that's
about so I made about 608k from that
method because I started with a mil um
so this concludes all the methods that I
want to go over in this this video
there's also a few other methods um I
might come out with a video later on
with those methods but anyways thanks
guys for watching and I hope this helps